[Music]
now filming is officially underway for
the Bachelorette here is Rachel Lindsay
and host Chris Harrison on night 1 at
the mansion in these new picks we
counted more than a dozen cameras
capturing at least 16 of Rachel's
potential suitors a diverse group she
told us she wanted I'm hoping my cast
reflects what America looks like no I
don't just state african-american man
I'm ready to go black and I'm never
gonna go back in a bachelor nation first
we met for them on Mondays after the
final rose
some fans said the surprise move was
because bachelor Knicks season was so
boring that Rachel's season had to start
early of course it was strategic in some
way last season's bachelor Ben Higgins
and his fiance Lauren Bushnell currently
filming a happily ever after cameo told
us
whatever the reason for the
bachelorettes early start it's all
positive how this world works right you
got to get eyes on the television but
what about theories that Nick and
Vanessa's awkward body language means
they're already broken up their
relationship is very real they weren't
trying to hide anything so I think
they're authentic you know Lauren I've
been there and we know that that time in
life is really hard
they were just being very honest Ben's
advice to Nick concentrate on a
relationship more than anything else but
you can't blame a guy for doing Dancing
with the Stars it's a great thing for
not only somebody financially but just
an experience that you won't ever have
again
[Music]
you